you know excuses aujourd'hui se trouve
pour la troisième fois sur ce point qui
s'amorce au jump scare le jeu final est
sorti on peut atteindre la 8e chambre la
chambre ultime the ultimate dans la
houle si m'apporta j'ai pas ce qui m'a
pris en tout cas on va tout de suite
lancé à partir de la chambre 750 va pas
s'amuser à tout refaire alors qu'on a
déjà fait les 750 première au je pensais
pas que tu arrivé jusque là
there you go 1 limited stamina merci
beaucoup je t'aime annoncée du million
mensonge peut plus courir bonjour la
chambre 750 et une à on va gentiment
aller jusqu'à la 1000e et ça va durer
2h30 voilà je vote à quoi vous
ressemblez les nouveaux monstres kawaii
quoi nous fuit son passé car oui ils
font par un peu un essai pas possible de
marcher si leur train en gare
c'est une torture quadri que je croise
le jeu l'uma à coups de hache est amer
bonjour c'est quoi ça à téléphone
as tu sais moi c'est la nouvelle coque
iphone à l'eau alors là ou alors à l'eau
ah bonjour comment ça va messieurs la
[ __ ] j'ai débuté gélade cooper de halo
ceci est le dernier essai elle n'avait
pas rendu mon demande d'énergie bord des
jeunes toujours pas courir ça va faire
mal
j'ai envie de ramper à 20,6 te plaît à
face aux c'est bon on fait juste faire
le west intermarché ça remarche h vers
l'ouest ou le temps qu'un supporter
damas ouais mais s'ajuste seul bon mais
ce cas petits lots à chaque vidéo j'en
peux plus je n'en peux plus le but et le
coupon de l'ucip usage tout coupé ou
droite what what what je me barre je
peux parler à manger un bon tiers monde
à celui qui a ralenti
you can't have mais peindre
par toi bartois bartois aaa barre toi et
m'a fait la vie je suis pas bien
imagina mais comment faire une petite
chambéon nier une petite chambre un
petit champ une petite chambre et on y
est
cet endroit est finalement en train de
l'affecter j'ai vu à sept films
d'horreur pour savoir comment survivre à
un simple fantômes ou deux mais ces
monstres vont de plus en plus vite et
sont plus en plus étrange
oui oh mon dieu ça c'est alors ça c'est
nouveau
alors ça c'est totalement nouveau mon
gars cela n'arrête étrange je pense que
les briques et le bois sont juste de la
peinture tout al'air faux j'ai aussi
entendu des mouvements et des voix
derrière moi peut-être d'autres
survivants se cache ici pas tellement
patel peut-être s'écrier de montreux su
peut-être que c'est une sorte d'hôtel ou
une autre entrée peu importe je pense
que c'est un bon endroit où rester
we have all à petit canal avant de voir
des trucs cachés ici je peux l'entendre
descendre le hall
je dois me cacher mais je sais pas où
j'ai réussi à me cacher mon appréhension
devant cette pièce dans un petit coin
sont aux prises forfait et talent
on va se faire défoncer feta ok si on
apprend la [ __ ] merde
penser que je peux sortir ou pas j'ai
peur c'est louche
gilles lellouche oh [ __ ] je ne sens
pas du tout je me cache
je suis caché à à juba la capitale est
passé à 20 h au pub la copa le coup
elles soient pas des bons sens de la
[ __ ] j avais peur qui nous attend dans
un coin sous gravats il a oublié une
claire au sud une des villes hôtes
héritage jamais vu ça merci et souk la
guide smisek something un livre
arrêt d'oublier contribuèrent savoure
encore plus peur alors que ensuite les
petits bouts pif paf boom en or [ __ ]
j'suis pas moyen je veux pas mourir
troquer une porte close qui nous amène
dans un souterrain encore [ __ ] un
choix tout droit une armoire
alors gardons de bons réflexes des jeux
de rome où il ya ça fait vingt minutes
qu'on a la chance 810 quoi c'est quoi
leur bac sans décote il s'est barré on
est en pays à une clé au faut que je
remonte là-haut me dit pas qui va errer
dans les couloirs mec non non fucking
way ensuite à part de sortie juste en
face de nous allez 38 ans batteur on
mourra pas mon gars si on marche coupe
la tête de tous ceux que je connais où
c'est un peu violent comme réaction
tu vois je marche sachant plus imposante
essaie tant bien que mal de faire 120 ch
allemand je trouve ce chiffre prend pas
mal plus tard vers la chambre 810 était
là masters épreuve et en espace rien
quoi tu veux juste que marché du rail
faut qu'on touche du bois est sinon le
saurai va nous jeter un mauvais sens à
nos merdes nous sommes dit le même poids
de benoît pont pierre objectif à geler
[ __ ] j'y allais voir du courrier
pendant des heures dans le pire endroit
du monde l'art de chambre c'est le plus
beau jour de ma vie
oh oui oh oui ouvre toi
[ __ ] sympa décor j'adore du parquet
qui l'a pensé lui terrifié j'aimerais
avoir le même artisan est ce que la
chambre 210 possède un petit secret tout
comme nation 810 910 [ __ ] c'est un
truc spécial de plus en plus de baleine
apparraisse autour de ces îles et je
n'arrive pas à trouver pourquoi je veux
juste vivre et à la chambre mille voilà
c'est mon objectif dans la vie
actuellement d'accord donc à des papiers
où il parle de 2,2 de baleines des
expériences qu'ils ont fait sur des
baleines boîte ya une [ __ ] palette tu
passes au roi mais c'est quoi ce délire
là sa part au but un atom soit vraiment
on soit dans un pré aquarium
[ __ ] c'est dingue en tous les cas je
m'en fous de mesures de bâle elle n'a
pas arrêté de faire semblant de créer
d'histoire et stoddart aussi à d'autres
il faut qu il faut une hanche
oh oh oui bla aller ok on est bien
baisés va peut-être un code dans une des
lettres
c'est là notre numéro 4 de poids tels
que le quatrième chef ces deux stages ou
comprendre certains 04
41 32 la liasse ou cette nature des
faits noté les mesures
oui là il ya une clé voilà alors aulas
ont atterri là c'est quoi ça water pour
me contrôler start stop us est jamais
sûr je pense que ça fait un jeu tourné
dans les premières pièces voit en
arrière
sinon dès maintenant la fasch rapport de
recherche numéro 7 tout le staff s'en
est allé il ne reste plus que moi pour
aucune raison je reste ici et je résiste
à la pelle qui vient de l'autre côté de
la porte scellée ne pas ouvrir cette
porte
c'est là qu'elle se brise alors à l'eau
ouais mais c'est bon on s'en est sorti
avec eux c'est pas du jeu wata des
bronches y moi j'ai juste des poumons
nul
ces diversions espèces de petites billes
à 83 cents à faire comme ça voilà la
passion passion pit 6
infernal gaza dure milan j'en peux plus
j'en peux plus oh oui la terre ferme
tiens t'as pris cher pour rien bah tu as
ta gueule on pourrait redonner ce jeu le
marathon du gamer je sais pas ce qui me
suivait mon gars ça a pas l'air gentil
du tout
oh mon dieu revient pas c'est là ça il
aurait 5 oh non j'ai diront les faits
ensemble mais du coup dern allait donner
un visage à faire ça on y est on y est
existe je vous laisse tous dans ce but
un bunker tous je me barre
le mode élégante qui font des pet ou
rose je suis libéré des livres et je ne
mentirai plus jamais ça veuille vista
sky fatale erreur tu dois passer un
dernier test days of the dead
ok
what au delà le titan colossal mais en
version beaucoup moins colossal
c'est quoi ça od barça combat pour rien
ouais c'est cool à part donc tiens oui
je te couper pied mois
moore howie [ __ ] enfin l'abordage j'en
avais marre la petite fille c'était le
titan colossal c'est ça non impossible
du train elle est trop mignonne je suis
mort c'était tragique et je suis devenu
un fantôme ne lève toi soldats
maintenant on à ses troupes pour envahir
je sais pas quoi elle m'a complètement
mener par le bout du nez
maintenant vous n'avez pu être adorable
vous n'allez plus être ignorée
maintenant vous êtes les monstres les
plus forts du monde
ok tu pensais vraiment que c'était la
fin bah ouais bah la preuve fusée la fin
[ __ ] énorme mais bon les gens s'y
enfoncer le doute sur ce point qu'ils
arborent fnac merci mots parce que le
gameplay tout coup mais c'est médiatique
type on a vraiment envie d'aller au bout
du jeu de le finir et le poste à péter
devant les copains à l'école primaire
mais à savoir regarder on se retrouve
très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
partez-vous bientôt en bis